- Oh, nah, what's, what's the green guy named?
- The Hulk. The Incredible Hulk.
- No. Nope. The other one.
- Flubber?
- Frankenstein.
- Is it Flubber?
[Laughing]
- I do this thing with everybody where
we play a game called Heads Up.
- Aw, hell.
- Have you played before?
- I've played before, yeah.
- Have you ever played that?
- Heads Up?
- Yeah.
- What is it?
- So you're trying to get me to guess,
like, the word that comes on the screen.
OK?
- OK.
- Aw, sh—you're gonna give
me them hard words.
- No, they're not hard.
They're not hard.
The first category is basketball.
OK?
- Yeah, I see it.
- I'm closing my eyes so I can't cheat.
OK.
Go.
- I can't say the words in that, right?
- No.
- Ahhhh.
Uhh.
- It's timed! You gotta talk...
- Yeah, I know.
I know.
I know. Uhh...
- Uhh, Damian Lillard's team.
- Portland Trail Blazers.
- Yes.
- This happens to me a lot off
the pick-and-roll, two people.
- Foul.
- No, two people coming at me.
- Double-teamed.
- Yup, yup, yup.
- Uh, intermission.
- Halftime.
- Teams go to the locker room.
- Yeah.
- Uh, Giannis score all
his points there.
- Milwaukee Bucks.
- No, he scores all his points
in this place on the court.
- Oh, the paint.
- Yup.
You got it.
- Best dunker of all time.
Best dunker of all time.
- Dominique Wilkins.
- No, no, no, no, no. Best dunker. Best dunker.
Ahh, Vince Carter.
- Ahh!
- Vince Carter's the—
- Nope, like, I'm a Hawks fan.
- Atlanta, Atlanta, yeah.
- I'm going to instantly think
Dominique Wilkins.
- Um, this dude wear glasses.
They, they, they got like their own game.
They be flyin'—
- Monopoly?
- On brooms and s--t.
- They be flyin' on brooms.
- Oh, Harry Potter.
- Yup, you got it.
- Harry Potter, Goblet of Fire.
Harry Potter, Sorcerer's Stone.
Harry Potter, Chamber of Secrets.
- That one. That one. That one.
- He's the dad of, uh, Draco.
- Oh, Lucius Malfoy.
- Yes.
- Oh, "You get a car, you get
a car, you get a car."
- Oprah Winfrey.
- Shaq. Charles Barkley.
- "Inside the NBA."
- It's a TV channel.
- TNT?
- Yeah.
- Uh, bald head and cleans everything.
It's a brand.
- Well, you can't say "clean." Is it Mr. Clean?
- Yes.
- But you can't, you—
- It's clean.
- Uh...huh?
No, no, skip it.
- Oh, it's a, it's umm, it's an alien on a bike.
- E.T.
- Yes.
- This guy is all wrapped up.
They dead. They all wrapped up.
- Mummy.
- Yup.
- Oh, whoever throws the pass.
Whoever passes the ball.
- Quarterback.
- Yes.
- Woo! In the clutch,
you got the final one.
Thank you for indulging me.
That was great.
It was Ellen Page.
Yeah.
- [Taylor, laughing]
Ellen Page is an actress.
- Yeah, no, the only other
Ellen I know is DeGeneres.
- [Laughing]